c'est quoi cette émission
très con
Gustavo vous avez un coniftueux
est-ce que vous pouvez montrer comment
faire allez
parce que vous êtes aussi vous êtes
aussi réputé pour le tri que vous faites
ah ouais le 1 apprends-moi le cri
OK
ok
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
Emmanuel gum à Paris dans les locaux
d'Arte bonjour je viens de durée de midi
de Jean qui est responsable ici à Arte
des programmes culture en fait depuis
trois ans je présente les événements
musique en direct donc les folles
Journée de Nantes les grands festivals
voilà et puis un peu mal aux dents
aujourd'hui malgré une rage de dents
l'animatrice enchaîne aujourd'hui les
rendez-vous en compagnie de coco son
chien
le deuxième rendez-vous se déroule dans
la société de production avec laquelle
Emmanuel tourne une série de
documentaires sur les mégapoles du monde
entier alors on va aller voir ensemble
les derniers tournages de prochaine
arrêt
donc on va voir les montages de Rio
parce que j'ai passé un peu plus de deux
semaines là-bas il y a un mois et puis
on va discuter un peu de la suite des
événements parce que là je reviens de
Los Angeles et je pars samedi donc dans
quelques jours à Pékin comme j'ai la
chance de voyager en famille c'est ce
que j'ai décidé de faire cette année
c'est dans d'emmener avec moi ma petite
fille de 8 ans et mon mari qui nous suit
et du coup Pékin j'y vais cinq jours
avant pour moi
moins sous le feu des projecteurs
Emmanuel mène une vie plutôt privilégiée
[Musique]
la jeune maman globe-trotteuse vient
visionner les dernières images tournées
c'était à Rome et on est désormais bien
loin de l'actu people qu'elle présentait
sur TF1 c'est le monsieur qui a mixé
le film
de Leone
[Musique]
ce que j'adore avec cette émission c'est
que quand je revois les trucs je me suis
waouh on a fait tout ça on a rencontré
tous ces gens on a été dans tous ces
endroits c'est dingue c'est comme un
rêve quoi
entre deux tournages comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et manuel profite de son
passage à Paris pour revoir ses amis je
dès que je repasse par Paris et on se
débrouille pour se faire
un thé un dîner enfin bref
des amis des vrais qui de toute évidence
font peu de cas de sa célébrité
cathodique
qui te ramène jamais un truc qui prend
la poussière d'un pays étranger ça c'est
formidable l'homme à sa droite c'est son
mari et le père de son enfant donc c'est
je crois que ça lui correspond bien
aussi cette idée de voyage de pouvoir
découvrir d'autres cultures rencontrer
des gens je crois que c'est important
pour elle c'est de rencontrer des gens
le dernier rendez-vous est à la fois
professionnel et très personnel on va
faire du shopping mais pour l'émission
je vais donc chercher des vêtements pour
faire ma petite valise pour pk
et la boutique de quartier remplaçait
les grandes marques du temps où elle
arpent elle est tapis rouge
[Musique]
allez viens mon coco
à la maison on va faire les valises
c'est bientôt l'heure du départ Emmanuel
prépare ses affaires elle emmène que le
nécessaire avec une place particulière
pour ce qu'il est en cas de coup dur
c'est du chocolat en fait
[Musique]
j'ai fait des tas de trucs qui me
faisaient pas forcément rêver pendant
des années en télé
et là je suis au cœur de ce que j'aime
non ça a pas l'air mais c'est route
pour Emmanuel chaque valise fermée et
poussée à l'autre bout du monde est un
pas de plus loin des chaînes privées qui
l'ont lancé
allez en route pour Pékin
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
Emmanuel goome Emmanuel bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde a parlé alors
vous êtes né le 28 septembre 1968 à
Saint-Mandé dans le Val-de-Marne dans un
hôpital militaire votre père était
médecin militaire mais enfin plus
médecin que militaires quand même
puisqu'il a profité de Mai 68 pour se
casser de l'armée mais en fait c'est
l'histoire d'un gosse qui était enfant
de troupe tu vois donc il a dû toutes
ces années d'études
aux militaires donc il a été obligé de
rendre ces années d'études à l'armée
c'est un gosse voilà exactement alors
vous n'êtes pas un très beau bébé
Emmanuel faut dire des choses
vous habitiez près du zoo de Vincennes
faut dire en même temps
alors vous avez six mois quand votre
famille déménage pour Annecy vous vivez
votre enfance dans une maison remplie de
livres entre une mère passionnée de
musique classique et un père qui vous
traîne dans les expos avant même que
vous ne sachiez marcher quelle chance
eux-mêmes puisque ma mère elle est
elle est fille de Jean de la campagne on
va dire mon père il est fils de
gendarmes donc on peut pas dire que ce
soit des des gens qui ont été baignés
dans la culture ils sont venus à la
culture quand ils étaient adolescents et
puis jeunes jeune adulte ils ont envie
ils ont vraiment eu envie de nous faire
ce Legg là très tôt donc tout petit déjà
il y a la musique il y a la danse il y a
les expos il y a tout ça c'est
incroyable quand j'y pense c'est un
cadeau phénoménal quoi énorme ça a
marché c'est le plus beau cadeau qui me
fait ouais non vraiment alors votre
passion à vous pour la musique née à
l'âge de 13 ans quand vous voyez un film
de Jean-Pierre Melville qui s'appelle
les enfants terribles et là vous
découvrez les concertos pour piano de
Bach et d'un seul coup c'est une
illumination pour vous
c'est vrai c'est un choc en fait aussi
de la danse et de l'équitation
vous aviez beaucoup d'énergie en fait je
faisais 17 heures de danse par semaine
et je montais à cheval quasiment tous
les jours parce que j'avais les Haras
nationaux qui étaient juste en bas de la
maison
alors après le bac fait un an de
d'hippocaigne
quand vous arrivez à Paris vous disais
comment
porte de porte d'Orléans le périmé là il
y a le pont pour aller à la Cité
universitaire il y a d'affreux HLM là je
suis au premier étage c'est ah tu vois
ça me donne envie de me sortir de là
assez vite tu vois
l'école française les attachés de presse
et vous avez votre premier boulot
attaché de presse dans une maison de
disque mais vous n'aimez pas le patron
qu'est-ce qu'il avait ce
[Musique]
patroncessions
vous restez jamais longtemps au même
endroit quoi vous partez souvent vous
êtes j'ai besoin d'être libre
de base en 1993 après avoir découvert le
chômage les entretiens d'embauche vous
retrouvez en train d'animer les matinal
de France Musique vous êtes à votre aise
là ça va je suis la plus jeune
animatrice de la Maison de la Radio à ce
poste-là sur le 7 9 c'est France Musique
bon c'est assez incroyable pour moi
parce que je suis fondu mordu de musique
classique en même temps je fais une
spécialiste j'ai passé des études j'ai
pas de doctorat musicologie rien de tout
ça donc je suis fierté incroyable cette
meuf quoi et c'est là que votre sœur
envoie une photo à Antoine de Caunes qui
anime nulle part ailleurs et qui chaque
soir prend une inconnue différente pour
faire la météo
et ça marche à l'époque ils veulent pas
de gens qui qui travaillent dans les
médias donc je vois au casting et je dis
je suis fleuriste en fait voilà et je
sors du casting je mets ma pauvre fille
pourquoi tu as été racontée que tu vends
des fleurs et je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
mis pendant une demi-heure j'ai raconté
mon métier de fleuriste
et donc il me rappelle et je dis à son
assistante écoute je menti pas possible
je fais le 7 9 sur France Musique et
donc on dit ça m'intéresse beaucoup une
jeune femme qui connaît bien la musique
classique a fait l'avenir donc vous
faites la météo et ça marche d'autant
mieux que Michel Field vous remarque
dans cette unique météo et vous embauche
pour faire des chroniques musique
classique dans le cercle de minuit sur
France 2 ça se passe très bien avec
Phild ça se passe très bien ouais c'est
un mec
qui qui comme moi c'est à dire enfin
il est pas issu de là je crois que c'est
une espèce de volonté de puissance
un désir de changer sa sa vie qu'il
conduit à la télé donc on a un espèce
d'énergie en commun comme ça voilà qu'on
se passe bien entre vous mais vous
repartez pour aller animer le matin
Express le 7 9 de M6 pourquoi parce que
je veux pas rester son assistante toute
ma vie je suis pas comme ça moi j'ai
besoin de faire ma vie d'exister par
moi-même de faire mes trucs à moi
sauf que M6 c'est épouvantable vous
dites sur M6 j'ai vécu le pire de la
culture téloche ah oui c'est très con
c'est vraiment la culture con quoi c'est
en fait c'est une vérité je te jure
qu'au
bout de balle aligner les sujets les
verbes et les compléments c'est en plus
on est vraiment tu sais dans la culture
clip dans la culture rap j'adore le rap
c'est pas le problème mais il y a un
moment tout le monde parle n'importe
comment et je me retrouve dans des
dîners tu vois parce que je suis un peu
je suis un peu schizo j'ai toujours ma
vie dans la musique classique je me
retrouve dans des dîner le soir très
chic et j'ose plus prendre la parole
tellement j'ai l'impression que mon
langage il s'est déliter en deux trois
ans et là je me dis au secours faut que
je parte de là
et après sur France 2 donc vous
rejoignez de Chavannes pour faire
téléquanone
c'est quoi cette émission
pas loin qui me faisait respirer de
l'hélium là pour me faire une voix
débile
quoi moi très longtemps je crois j'ai
essayé de tenir mais j'ai pas pu là vous
vous retrouvez avec moi
sur rive droite rive gauche donc sur
Paris Première ça durait combien de
temps pas longtemps écoute une petite
saison je crois ou deux peut-être très
mal payé
ses débiles chez toi génial mais alors
payer des cacahuètes donc faut trouver
autre chose
après c'est Arthur donc vous retournez
sur TF1 pour une chronique aux enfants
de la télé
les premières émissions des ouais des
personnalités de la télé d'hier
d'aujourd'hui c'était vachement bien
alors là ça se passe très bien mais vous
quittez encore ah non je reste vous
restez pour faire exclusive
exclusif avec Frédéric Joly ce qui était
vraiment bien c'est que c'était le
premier JT people donc c'était une
aventure c'était marrant de le faire bon
voilà quoi voilà donc là TF1 et vous
partez au bout de deux ans je sais pas
pourquoi je pars parce que ça fait deux
ans parce que c'est fait
parce que j'en ai marre d'écrire tous
les jours des conneries sur les people
voilà c'est ça en vérité c'est que
j'écris tous mes machins tous les jours
alors j'arrive le plus tard aussi pour
que ça prenne le moins de temps possible
à côté tu sais j'ai toujours ma vie
musique
j'anime des concerts public dans tous
les orchestres de français de Navarre
voilà il faut bien gagner ça fait bête
ou avec Thierry Dujon et Philippe Vandal
vous animez nulle part ailleurs là c'est
une espèce de consécration quand même
non en fait j'ai du mal à parler comme
ça pour moi non c'est pas une
consécration mais c'est de greffe voilà
donc c'est Alain degreffe on s'était
croisé quand j'avais fait ma petite
mettaito il m'avait vu genre 15 jours
plus tard au cirque de minuit c'était
d'ici quoi cette nana qui vient chez moi
une fois qui se retrouve engagée 15
jours après ils pensaient que j'étais
quelqu'un tu vois qu'il y avait tout
calculé donc en bref il voulait plus
entendre parler de moi mais moi je
trouvais que c'était une personnalité
vraiment intéressante donc j'avais d'un
côté moujotent qu'un type formidable
très bien élevé très cultivé mais qui me
propose d'animer je sais pas quoi un
truc débile sur TF1 et j'ai de l'autre
côté
Alain qui me fait ça tu vois et qui me
dit nulle part ailleurs si je fasse vous
acceptez vous acceptez sauf que ça se
passe très mal ça se casse la gueule en
trois mois
donc là vous êtes très star quels ont
été les réactions de votre entourage la
famille papa maman ils sont fiers et les
potes ils vous Charriez un peu du fait
d'être sur TF1 d'être sur Canal mes
potes dans le milieu donc mes potes dans
le milieu c'est qui c'est ta déi c'est
big BD ils sont tous de ma gueule mais
bon ça ils empêche pas de s'amuser avec
moi et de déconner là-dessus le soir tu
vois et puis non c'est enfin tu sais ce
que c'est la télé quand ça marche et que
ta tête en couverture des magazines
étaient respectées que tu fasses de la
merde ou quelque chose de bien tu es
respecté et avec les médias comment ça
s'est passé pour moi bien c'est à dire
que je refuse à peu près tout c'est on
me dit tu vas prendre un avion tu vas
aller te poser sur le Walk off Fame à
Los Angeles j'en fais non moi je veux
pas 48 heures à Los Angeles pour poser
sur vos coffeech ça débile donc soit
vous me payez 10 jours à elle je fais
plein de trucs intéressants et au
passage on va faire la photo sur le sur
le sinon non donc c'est vrai que je suis
pas non je suis pas je suis pas très
sympa avec tous ces gens enfin je joue
pas tellement de jeux et l'argent j'ai
gagné de l'argent à cette époque
beaucoup
comme ça au moins c'est fait ça tu vois
bah ouais ouais
au niveau mec ça vous a ah bon célébrité
fille quand tu es une fille la célébrité
c'est une cata
soit les starfuckers qui sont autour de
toi et mon général c'est c'est tu vois
c'est le niveau est quand même pas très
élevé soit tu peux avoir des types très
bien mais qui envisagent pas de se
mettre au bras une fille qui est tous
les soirs sur TF1 c'est pas possible
à ce niveau là
c'est les pires années de ma vie
sentimentalement c'est les pires de ma
vie le meilleur moment de cette époque
ça a été quoi j'aurais tendance à dire
c'est tous les moments où je faisais pas
ça
quand il a été évident que ce nulle part
ailleurs version soir était un échec
quoi ça marchait pas non mais je crois
que c'est un peu pire que ça je crois
que c'est le moment où Messi arrive et
décide de tout voilà donc il paye un mec
très cher Alexandre Bobigny pour virer
tout le monde bon c'est pas très
agréable mais en même temps moi j'ai un
contrat magnifique tu vois donc je suis
parti danger quoi d'abord il me redonne
une émission pour terminer l'année tu
vois l'honneur
je coupe mes cheveux j'enfile des
petites vestes propres et c'est parti et
je le fais vraiment pour terminer
proprement et puis oui j'encaisse le
chèque et je m'achète un appartement
c'est pas mal NPA ce n'est pas mon échec
c'est celui d'Alain degreffe ça
parce que je pense pas que ce soit
aujourd'hui je pense pas du tout que ce
soit l'échec de de grave je pense que
c'est l'échec de la politique de canal à
l'époque ça allait bien au-dessus de
bien au-delà d'Alain je pense c'était
d'avoir cru qu'on pouvait remplacer
Antoine de Caunes partir et du genre
l'échec non c'est possible il était
particulièrement sinistre il faut dire
notre ami il est toujours je suis
d'accord avec toi alors aujourd'hui vous
êtes nostalgique de cette époque je suis
nostalgique du brin de pouvoir en plus
que ça me donnait pour mener à bien mes
projets
la notoriété évidemment c'est une c'est
une porte d'entrée extraordinaire donc
il y avait beaucoup de types qui avait
plein d'argent qui me donnaient plein de
sous pour faire des choses dans le
milieu de la musique classique par
exemple ils m'en donnent beaucoup moins
aujourd'hui c'est mon seul regret et si
c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne
referiez pas pareil alors écoute
peut-être finalement je quitterai pas
TF1 tu vois ouais j'écouterai couture
Xavier Couture
qui me dit vraiment tu as déconné
complètement et peut-être que à ce
moment là où vraiment ça marchait très
fort pour moi il aurait fallu que je
comprenne que c'était aussi un business
machin là et que ça pouvait me servir à
faire d'autres choses à côté
mais c'était voilà je raisonnais pas
vraiment comme ça d'ailleurs je
malheureusement je continue
le jour vous allez mourir
vous voulez qu'on écrive quoi sur votre
temps Emmanuel écoute quelque chose
comme comment faut-il prendre la pente
monte elle n'y pense pas mal merci c'est
très heureux allumer la lumière sur
vous-même merci beaucoup et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de Inna larditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu